on
the topic of decentralized exchanges uh
what kind of decentralized exchanges dex
is what are they first of all and
what kind would you like to see built
around cardano
yeah so people want to create exchanges
that don't have custodial risk
the point of exchange is to build you a
marketplace where
bids and ass can find each other market
people can meet
and trade you can find a price and you
get liquidity
so you know you got gold you want to
turn your gold into dollars
okay well somebody has to create a
marketplace for that so like coinbase is
an
example marketplace but it's centralized
but the problem is you have custodial
risk so when you put your gold and your
dollars your digital representations of
these things
into the exchange what if you know wally
he was eve broke up with him and now
he's really sad and he's gone to the
dark side he's become wally the hacker
okay so he can go and sneak his way in
and hack into coin base and steal all
your
your gold and your tokens so instead of
you actually being able to swap these
things you've lost all your money
there's other problems too like let's
say you know
daisy has now come in and become a
regulator and said oh i don't like these
exchanges anymore i'm just going to shut
them all down
yeah and then you have no access to it
so you have sovereign risk you have the
risk of threat you have regulatory risk
you have the issue of banks maybe
cutting you out so
it's been in our industry for more than
10 years mount gox was the most famous
example of that they collapsed i believe
in 2013 and hundreds of millions of
dollars was lost
over the course of a while so the point
of a dex is saying can we do
what a marketplace does but not have
coinbase not have a central actor run
this thing
and there's a lot of problems with that
because exchanges are generally
uh creatures of latency you know high
frequency trading for example these
things the nanosecond they co-locate
their infrastructure with the exchange
software just so they can front run
orders over
other people i mean it's crazy the
amount of technology that they put in
so the traditional wall street version
of an exchange is very centralized very
fast very optimized
and kind of behaves by a very close set
of rules
when you look at a dex you have to
accept that you're going to have
to have slightly different rules because
you're operating at a global systems
latency
and you're operating a system that has
different behaviors however that said
there's a lot of great protocols that
have been built for it you know unit
swap has kind of evolved a lot over the
years
uh and we've seen a huge competition and
a lot of
evolution to basically build out
protocols that kind of excuse some of
these security problems enjoy high
liquidity
and then also have this beautiful uh
concept of openness
one of the gatekeepers to crypto when
you're a cryptocurrency developer are
the exchanges
i remember when we first created cardano
you know the the we
the bitfinex guys reached out at the
cardinal foundation they said oh we'd be
happy to list data
and i said okay and they said yeah we
want five million dollars to do it
you know so there was kind of a some
italian for go yourself in those
email
conversations i think hula is what
i said
um but uh but anyway there was that kind
of back and forth happens all the time
and and because these guys are
gatekeepers they they have this nepotis
to control information asymmetries and
so forth
so having a dex you don't have that
problem you have open listing
and you basically just put the asset
into it and if anybody wants to trade it
they will
and if it seems like it's a good idea a
natural market will form market making
will occur and you get liquidity with it
so there's no barrier to entry for that
type of system
the biggest existential problem for
dexa's right now is the concept of
regulation
uh so basically right now when you use
binance or
coinbase or these other guys you have to
go through kyc and aml know your
customer and anti-money laundering
so basically who are you and you know is
your money real or not or are you drug
dealer or something
so normally you do that by saying okay
i'm going to give them my
copy of my passport and maybe they're
going to request some tax records or
whatever the best practices are for the
particular jurisdiction
and then that exchange is liable if
that's up
so the government comes in and says hey
guys uh
you know we pull your compliance records
and they find discrepancies
they'll actually put the exchange out of
business or find them very heavily
jpmorgan chase got 19 billion dollars in
finance
and fines over the last 20 years for
various compliance issues amongst other
things
so it's expensive a very difficult thing
and at dex it's
open system you just have value coming
in not identity
and so all these things are trading
amongst anonymous accounts and so
there's no notion of compliance right
now for that
so a lot of regulators are coming in and
saying oh well this is just a cesspool
for terrorism and drug dealing and bad
stuff and they
they're word salad of of but
you know it is what it is you have to
deal with these guys and so
there's been a lot of discussions of can
we take dexes and we keep the
openness and keep the liquidity and no
counterpart or custodial risk
and can we add some notion of compliance
to that
in a decentralized way that doesn't
require a single actor to be a
gatekeeper
so i think actually by combining dids
decentralized identifiers that's the way
to do it but it's actually the next
generation of the technology it's the
regulated decks and
you know who regulates that how does
that work and so forth but i think
ultimately those are going to be the
only marketplaces that uh
end up surviving in this current
environment if your desire is to exit to
a dollar
if you don't really care about the fiat
side like a traditional legacy currency
you can always do things in a shadowy
unreal
unregulated way but i mean it's a
personal preference
and a business preference
you